good day everyone and welcome I'm Jack
Van Horn from the University of Virginia
and I'm very proud to welcome you to
this edition of our 2022 2023
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series the seminar series is
supported by uva's integrated
translational Health Institute of
Virginia the UVA brain Institute the
College of Arts and Sciences the school
of data science and through a grant from
the National Institutes of General
Medical Sciences since 2016 the
foundations of biomedical data science
seminar series is focused on the use of
data science methodologies artificial
intelligence deep learning and
statistical modeling as they pertain to
different themes in the area of
biomedical and Health Sciences and this
year's theme is data science and the
public health consequences of the
covid-19 pandemic where we enjoy
presentations on Fridays at noon Eastern
from leading thinkers about the issues
promise opportunities and hurdles
associated with understanding the
secondary health effects of the covid-19
virus these include delayed Health
checkups treatment mental health issues
drug abuse increased obesity and long
lingering long covet effects that some
people experience as a consequence of
having suffered from the virus
participants selected for a biomedical
data science Innovation lab program will
leverage these presentations as vital
material in our in-person culminating
Grant project development Workshop to be
held at the lodge at St Edwards Park in
Seattle Washington in June of 2023.
today I'm delighted to welcome our
speaker Wilbert panwis from the National
Institutes of Health in Bethesda
Maryland a Wilbert earned his MD in 2004
followed by a PhD in global disease
epidemiology and control from uh the
Johns Hopkins University in 2009. Wilbur
is a globally recognized leader in data
science for public health with an
established track record for improving
access and use of data for public health
research he has been highly successful
in building large-scale International
Partnerships for data sharing data
integration and data driven research on
infectious diseases with Scientists from
various disciplines and government
Health agencies at international
national and local levels
Wilbur is currently serving as the
senior scientific officer and director
of The
niaid Office of data science and
emerging Technologies at the NIH and in
continuing our 2022-2023 biomedical data
science seminar series theme today's
lecture is entitled what can data
science do in the fight against
infectious and immune-mediated diseases
in his presentation today Wilbert's
going to discuss how infectious and
immune mediated diseases continue to
pose a major threat to human health as
illustrated by the recent covid-19
pandemic as well as continued burden of
long-term diseases such as HIV AIDS
tuberculosis malaria and many others
data science has already disrupted many
of the segments of society and holds
promise to transform the biomedical
landscape as well through Precision
medicine and AI supported decision
making and Wilbert is going to take us
through all that he is going to
highlight the vision of the U.S National
Institutes of allergy infectious
diseases for data science in the global
fight against infection and Immunity
diseases and we really look forward to
hearing about that as always we are
streaming this lecture live and for
recording by
watching on YouTube thank you for
joining us also our specially selected
22 2022 2023 biomedical data science
Innovation lab participants and alumni
are encouraged to submit any questions
they have by the chat feature in their
Zoom sessions I will synthesize these
questions and ask them on your behalf
during the last 10 minutes or so of the
lecture and with that welcome Wilbur we
are super excited to hear from you about
your vision and about what's up at the
National Institutes of Health thank you
thanks Jack uh very nice thank you for
the introduction
um so as I mentioned I will talk about
what data science can do in the fight
against infectious immunity diseases
um and um let's get right into it
um this first kind of notion that got me
uh partly into this field
um I'm of a background in epidemiology
and in medicine and moved over to
looking more at data science and data
access and here is this notion that you
can fight Ebola with information this is
a usaid report and
um it's intriguing how you can think
about data and information and digital
Technologies to really have a major role
in
um in addressing
a new emerging disease threats as well
as
chronic
present infectious diseases around the
world
I will today uh give you an introduction
and vision of where we are at niaid in
terms of data science also more
specifically our strategy and thinking
towards a niad data ecosystem talk a bit
about data sharing and then some trans
niaid data science funding opportunity
announcement fellowships that may be of
interest to this group and
um
moving forward so a little bit about
niaid this institution is one of the 27
institutes and centers of the U.S
National Institutes of Health the
mission is to conduct and support basic
and applied research to better
understand treat and ultimately prevent
infectious immunologic and allergic
diseases
so I think this is a good thing to
realize as we're thinking about the role
of niaid and the bigger picture of data
science and health is that this Mission
area is where most of our application
areas are going to be taking place it
also has a mandate The Institute to
respond to emerging Public Health
threats therefore there has been a major
role for nyad in the response against
source code V1 also recently source code
V2 but also Ebola flu pandemics and
other vaccines threats in the past
nyad has in fiscal year 2021 awarded
about 6 000 research grants and
contracts at about 5 billion US Dollars
it's one of the largest institutes at
NIH and you can also see the enormous
excitement about the potential
um
impact that data science could have from
nyad with this amount of research being
driven there are also very prominent in
major intramural research labs and I'll
explain a little bit about that
including the vaccine Research Center so
these are research Labs that conduct
research inside NIH and there are major
data science programs and training
programs as well in the intramural labs
the Strategic priorities of Nye in terms
of the biomedical science are clearly
SARS Kobe 2 and covid-19 thinking about
vaccination and Universal vaccine
against coronavirus Universal influenza
vaccine medical countermeasures for
re-emerging and emerging diseases HIV
vaccine prevention and treatment and
prevention and treatment of immune
mediated diseases and especially focus
on immune tolerance so these are the
type of kind of biomedical major
strategic priorities
now a bit about our office our office is
relatively new and
um the office of data science emerging
Technologies so first I'd like to point
you to these
um divisions we have so there is the
office of science management and
operations which is driving the
management of the of the Institute is
also the office of the chief of staff of
the director and then there is the
different intramural extramural
divisions the intramural divisions
conduct research in inside and iaid
there is a division of intramural
research clinical research in the
vaccine Research Center and extramural
divisions include the division of
microbiology and infectious diseases
allergy immunology and transplantation
and the division of AIDS and then
there's the division of external
activities where the operations mostly
reside and also the training grants are
being managed
our office is in the layer that goes
across all of the divisions uh here's
the office of data science that we are
in there's also the office of Global
Research the budget office other types
of offices inside this trans niaid layer
of the organization that means that we
are not placed in any of the particular
divisions but our work is cross-cutting
and that gives us a really nice
opportunity to look across all of the
activities that take place at niid and
then align them to best as possible
Advance the data science methods and
approaches
um going into a bit more of our team
here
um so I'm the director of the team we
are recruiting at this moment the deputy
uh there was also uh kind of two major
kind of uh areas of activities one is
the data science research and training
activities where we have staff and then
there is data science policy and
guidance where we also have uh staff and
again there are some positions that we
are still hoping to fill in the near
future
um and as mentioned we collaborate
extensively with staff across all of the
nine divisions our office is not an
intramural lab we do not conduct actual
data science research we also do not
fund major parts of research we do only
some and I'll show you some of that most
of our role is to coordinate and to
communicate and to bring the divisions
into alignment on data science as much
as possible in very strategic areas and
I'll show you that
uh so what um the office is really doing
it's the mission is to accelerate
intramural in is infectious media
diseases accelerate the research by
expanding and improving the use of data
science methods and Technologies we are
looking at both intramural and
extramural activities there is a
research program that we're looking at
in terms of how data science can
accelerate biomedical research in
effective and immune diseases there's a
training program we'd work on Community
Development and policy as well
and um
with that I would kind of want to go
into the data science for in fact she's
a little bit more and for immunity
diseases so using and so why do we need
an office of data science why do we need
to pay attention to this now using data
for science is not new it goes way back
as an epidemiologist I have to give the
example of Jon Snow in London in 1854
when there was a major cholera outbreak
as was not uncommon at the time and Jon
Snow very well known tallied all the
deaths due to cholera and displayed them
here on the map by address
and each address has a number of deaths
and he found that the largest
concentration of these deaths were
around this pump which led him to
believe that the water supply through
that pump
could cause or maybe one of the causes
of the cholera outbreak and then very
famously The Story Goes that he took the
handle off the pump and that the
outbreak actually reduced so here you
can see an excerpt from his actual book
and the article written about this pump
so that's so that is using data for
Science and I think this is what the
data must have looked like you know is
this is Broad Street and there is
addresses here 15 16 17 and that would
be number of deaths due to cholera and
so this is the sheet that you know may
have been used so you don't need an
office of data science to coordinate
this work and you know this type of work
has happened in in for a long time so
what's different now is that we're
looking at different layers and
complexities so here is an example of
from World pop a project to estimate
population counts where they use 10 data
layers to estimate population all at a
100 meter resolution these 10 layers
include satellite imagery remote sensing
lent use coverage population counts and
lots of other types of data at a very
high resolution and then the data
integration workflow here consists out
of numerous steps just to bring that
data together and then their estimation
models to really come up with the best
possible estimate based on the data of
these population caps this is clearly
very relevant for in fact he's an
immunity diseases if you want to know
how many people are living in a certain
area in the world and so the complexity
of the data here and the data
integration and in the methodology use
is so far beyond what Jon Snow was doing
that you start to kind of need special
expertise
here is the counterpart where worldpop
is sharing their data sets they have 50
45
000 data sets right now and sharing all
these data in an effective way so that
others can use and benefit from that is
not trivial you need to really think
about how to set up the systems and the
platforms for that and that takes a lot
of work so that is all sound expertise
that does that doesn't easily come in
your typical biomedical training program
and so data science is becoming needed
here is another example of clinical data
we may all know about the national covet
cohort collaborative managed by ncats
where they combine data there is when I
last looked 15 billion rows about 13
million people in this
in this database and papers are coming
out that look at the combining EHR data
here in this case 2 million patients
from 34 sites to look at risk factors uh
for covet outcomes and this type of
research again using these amounts of
data that become more and more
ubiquitous and the methods used become
so complex that again there is a new
kind of look uh need to to have better
coordination of these methods and that's
why we need an office of data science
we know that the amount of data
generated will continue to grow
based on the cost that is reduced for
for example sequencing but also other
sensors and other methodologies used to
really increase the number of the amount
of data available the challenges are
also increasing to effectively manage
and use the data where do we store this
data how do we use it effectively is
becoming a major question that you need
specialized experience then there are
the methodologies new methodologies and
here I'm using the example of artificial
intelligence the new methods emerge from
computational scientific disciplines
these methods do not come from the
biomedical Sciences they are coming from
other disciplines such as computer
science or mathematics and we see the
opportunity to apply these methodologies
in biomedicine and that translation is
not trivial think about using deep
learning Predictive Analytics
translation classification information
extraction text-to-speech and speech to
text image recognition Machine Vision
are all highly relevant for biomedical
research including research on effective
enemy immunity diseases but you again a
typical biomedical training program or
typical biomedical scientists like
myself
do not know how to use these methods we
don't understand them or we will not be
able to develop them and so there is
this explicit translation component
that's really important
so what is data science with all this
why why do we need data science so NIH
has a nice definition I think that
points out to three kind of components
one is there are large and complex data
involved secondly there is extracting of
knowledge involved from that data using
computational methods
and the methods become more and more
complex the data become more and more
complex and then there is an
interdisciplinary or multi-disciplinary
community of biomedical scientists and
computational scientists and also many
others but kind of illustrating with
these two kind of counterparts where we
would like to Foster and bringing these
kind of different groups together which
is not something that happens naturally
you need some nudging in many cases here
are some kind of application areas that
you could see in the nyad space of data
science things like intelligent vaccine
design using AI for vaccine design Alpha
fold was of course very important for
protein structures and looking at
Therapeutics computational Immunology
but also model estimations and com and
systems modeling many many more methods
you can think of applied here to in fact
is an immunity diseases in the night
admission area
now we have some strategic goals that
are still kind of preliminary but that
are going to solidify more and more
moving forward one is to improve data
access and use data are really key to
data science and we really need to
improve the access and use in many cases
where we're seeing enormous advantages
of computational methods the lack of
data access are really one of the big
bottlenecks so that's number one for us
then there is developing and improving
the use of computational methods as I
said already the fostering of a
multi-disciplinary community and then
the governance framework we need ethical
and Equitable use of data and
computational tools in this space
no
now I'll go a little bit more
specifically towards
the 90 ecosystem again trying to see
what what the vision is of where we want
to go in terms of the data access and I
have to say a lot of this talk here I
focus a lot on the data a part of data
science uh Less on the computational
methods because twofold one is
um
that's where we think is the main
challenge to address and also where we
can make a lot of improvement and also
where my own background expertise is
mostly in around data access as Jack
already mentioned
now looking here at the overall picture
of trans 9 data science initiatives we
want to go towards a network of fair
data and services for infectious and
immune the immune mediated disease
research
and there's kind of a pathway there is
data data needs to be curated put in
repositories connect to the ecosystem
and then integrated and analyzed
the making Fair part is the first kind
of four boxes and then the analytics
part is building on that
and and here's a depiction of the
ecosystem Vision that we have and I'll
go into that in more detail
so first of all that a lot of data on
infectious energy diseases are not in
repositories are not ready to go and be
used by lots of other people in very
effective ways a lot of the data are
located in journal supplements
University websites personal websites or
Labs like I had a lab in University of
Pittsburgh and we put web data on the
website from our lab and let others use
it or even on personal computers without
any discoverability online which you can
call dark data because nobody knows that
that data even exists so that's what the
situations in many instances
now data curation itself preparing data
for others to use is complex but a
necessary piece of work especially for
data science if you want to if you want
to have an AI algorithm or machine
learning algorithm the data needs to be
in a certain way a certain format to be
able to use that and many data don't
come in this format there's a curation
necessary so there's the data cleaning
and harmonization part does the quality
control
re-representing data in ways that
machines can understand it
standardization and also creating
metadata
and so oftentimes that is seen as a very
time-consuming task up to even 80
percent of the work of data scientists
goes to data preparation
and so we really want to move to a world
where
data science methods can be used and the
data are only cleaned and prepared once
for everybody to then benefit from how
do we get there is a more complicated
question
fair is part of the answer so fare is
been around since 2016. it's been used
in many different ways
including ways that are not fair
but we want to use Fair as a roadmap for
data curation
so the fair principles delineate
requirements for findability
accessibility interoperability and
reusability of data
not for humans but for computer
algorithms especially Ai and so fare is
really meant to improve AI Readiness of
data it's not necessarily focused on
humans but in our view once we prepare
data and we need to move towards
preparing data for computer algorithms
humans will also be able to use it in
much more effective ways and so it's
almost like a welcome side effect or
maybe a first step
um and fair is not many things right
fair is not open fair is not
um uh and and fair does not necessarily
um
mean that they'd have to be open we'll
get into that a little bit but I want to
stay true to what the what the
principles really denote and here you
could see them there are 15 principles
and I think um with a lot of hype terms
and a lot of Highly used kind of jargon
type terms there's a lot of potential
for misunderstanding or or even using
the terms without
um preserving its actual
meaning and value and I think for
example
um if fair is used in terms of trying to
make data open
um or or make it as in the same
um use it as an as an alternative to
open data then it kind of loses some of
this because nowhere here it says that
it has to be freely accessible to
anybody that wants to use it
um or Fair only for humans right the
idea here is really for machines and so
you can take away from the value of this
by sometimes looking over the details so
I really want to focus on these 15
technical principles that are here and
that we all want to meet as many as
possible and when they are really met
there is really tremendous benefit that
we can get from there so I don't want to
reinvent the wheel I'm just going to
build we are just going to build on
these principles to move towards our
ecosystem
Fair has actually gotten into you know
that has been the advantage of the kind
of
um catchy term uh and also the value of
the concept that it has penetrated in
large large parts of the world including
in the fiscal year 23 U.S government
budget priorities set by the White House
where it says that agencies should
prioritize making federally funded r d
open to the public so that is the kind
of connotation that fair is not
necessarily also open but this one
requires asked to be open prioritize
that but also findable accessible
interoper reusable way that then will
lead to more rigorous reproducible
transparent research as well but
grounded in assessment of ethical legal
and Society implications so there is
some caveats here but fair is still
quite squarely in this
budget
so going a little bit into what is so
important about metadata metadata is
really a key to data Discovery using
impact and to fair and so a lot of focus
will be on metadata here you could see a
data landscape
with all kinds of data Assets in it
and only a few have metadata that are in
a format that can be index in a catalog
and this is the catalog the researcher
here can use the catalog to find the
metadata search the metadata and then
find the data sets that the metadata are
linking to
right and so what we want is that all
that data gets metadata and that all
that metadata will be indexed in this
catalog and that's the first step for
people to be able to search and find
data sets that are out there based on
metadata that's kind of the um the
overarching idea
now metadata I have requirements they
need to be structured and they need to
be standardized so here you could see
the kind of a denotion of data and
metadata here's a data file there was a
metadata file in some format that
describes what's in this data file it
could be all kinds of things can be
things like an identifier for the
metadata and for the data creators and
who contributed to the data what's the
title what's the license what's the
scope what's the what's how was the data
derived all kinds of informations in
that metadata that helps humans but also
machines computers to understand this
data file and so what we do not want we
want it to be structured and standard we
do not want this description here that
says this file has been generated by
Wilbert from Penthouse and anybody who
wants to use it can go to my website and
make an account and then download the
data
etc etc I mean that is not structured
and that's not standard so computers
will have a really hard time
understanding this but humans 2 will
have a hard time understanding this so
in the end we want to go to these
structured ways so the structure is
machine readable standard terminology
and the beauty of metadata is that it
can be separated from the data the
metadata can be going to all kinds of
catalogs can be distributed and shared
widely
while the data stay in one place
and data access can be governed by
specific Rules by specific principles
and it can privacy can be protected and
proprietary information can be protected
that can all stay there the metadata is
the part that will go around the world
to let people know that the data are
there
there are some questions sometimes about
where the metadata goes if it's not
together with the data now there was a
very nice kind of examples here here is
a example of a repository where the
metadata are in the same place as the
data
so fixture you can upload your data and
what you will see is a um a human
readable
text here that describes this data set
and the data set are also right there
you can click that link and download the
data set so the data set and the
metadata are together
um but they also have a machine readable
version of this metadata that you can
see here right so they have both and
computers can understand that metadata
but now there is also places where
metadata are located that do not contain
data not uncommon as I said the metadata
can be separated from the data and
actually PubMed is one of the best known
examples where nobody goes to PubMed to
download papers you know that the papers
are somewhere else
right there's links to the papers but
the papers are not in PubMed you go to
PubMed to find papers based on the
metadata and that metadata points back
to the papers and then if you don't have
a subscription to the paper you cannot
access that paper you have to go and pay
for that paper as a journal and then you
can get the the the the paper from the
gym so you have to do your own
arrangement with the repository PubMed
doesn't deal with that it just points to
it and so that's an example of how we
can use metadata to give information
after the meta and their curation the
data should be deposited in a
professional repository this is in line
with the new NIH guidelines I'll go into
that in a little bit and there's a
notice here about how to how to select
repository but there is really benefits
of using a professional repository there
is backup Storage security access
transfer all these kind of things so
when I was a researcher in the lab at
Pittsburgh University of Pittsburgh we
had a lot of data we'd put it on our own
website on our own server Etc looking
back I'm thinking we should have put the
data in a repository then we don't need
to worry about the storage and the
backups and all these things the
repository thinks about that all that we
do is point to the data in the
Repository
um the repositories often uh help with
creating structured metadata that's
indexed and search enabled
um often has better sustainability than
Labs on personal websites because some
of them have business models that will
make them
um move into the future and it's easier
overall to improve fare compliance when
the data are in repositories than if the
data are in 6 000 different research
labs and so the repository kind of
strategy is going to be really useful
here and there are many repositories I'm
listing here A whole bunch for different
types of diseases different pathogens
different different
um types of data that we can all benefit
from
and then connecting those repositories
to the ecosystem and so I'm going into
the next few slides a little bit more
about the ecosystem what that looks like
there is a search portal as I mentioned
where researchers can find data software
and services that are in the ecosystem
some some place you need to be able to
search what's in this ecosystem
and then use it
and the search portal has some kind of
an antenna this is kind of very
um conceptual but this is where we want
to go then there are different
repositories in the community and they
have this kind of
Beacon that will transmit metadata
that can be received by this antenna and
can be picked up so the idea here of the
lines I'm trying to make them as as as
fine as possible they are not hard
bolted connections that are specific to
each repository and that need to be
maintained in a very rigorous way they
are
standards that the repositories are
using for transmitting the information
and that's what fair is if they're Fair
they can transmit Fair metadata
and then the portal can pick that up and
index it and that's how it will be used
but this is not the only portal other
portals will be able to also pick up
those signals there is no kind of
locking in of the exact only one one
portal can do it the same with the web
services you can see the web services
have transmitters but also antenna so
they can they can interact with the
repulse they can also be indexed in the
repository and then the software tools
who can also be discovered by web
services or by uh portals so the idea
here is really for a very Loosely
defined Network where certain standards
are used for the communication of
information
but that there's not going to be so
specific and hard bolted that it becomes
a very fragile system now of course the
technical implementation of this vision
is still incredibly challenging and I'm
not going to show you solutions for that
but this is the vision that we want to
move towards
um as I said a distributed network of
fair data and services for research on
effective immunity disease research
where the nodes in the network expose
Fair compliant metadata where nodes of
data enabled data visiting which means
algorithms can come
ask questions through the data and then
return answers without moving the data
around
um the data could stay where they are
there should be machine actionable
access controls so that data are
protected and can only be used for what
they have permission for and the the
model is open and Federated so nodes can
appear and disappear based on community
needs and activities if somebody wants
to build a web service that web service
can be there and connect to all the data
if the if the need for this web service
disappears then web service can
disappear the whole system will not
collapse because of that
um and this is not a new idea we've
taken this straight from the Gopher
foundation and the the fair movement
that has come up out of the paper uh
where there is the idea now in Europe to
set up the internet of fair data and
services here
in a very analogous way we can think of
that at for the niid space and then of
course
um uh there is this this new way of
thinking about distributed and
decentralized learning I put the paper
here about swarm learning for
decentralized and confidential clinical
machine learning where this example is
used where the data can stay
at the hospital systems that are not
need to move but the algorithm goes and
visits the data and does its computation
and brings only the results that it is
permitted to bring to the centralized
learning platform
that's where we want to go as well
so there is a portal in development
um that has been made this is kind of
like the PubMed for night relevant data
and software and we hope to release this
in the spring of this year so stay tuned
for that to see what's in the ecosystem
the vision for the ecosystem here I
mentioned already so there is a search
portal and there's a repos and the
software tools and rep services but also
the people so the ecosystem is also a
network for biomedical and computational
scientists to work together for many of
these components and not only scientists
we want the ecosystem to be fair
compliant because when it's fair
compliant the network becomes ready to
use for computational algorithms and Ai
and that's why I posted AI as well AI
will play a role and also other
computation algorithms in conjunction
and complementary to the researchers
that are in the network and then of
course the access controls that are
going to be really important they're not
only technical components but they're
also governance framework that needs to
be developed for ethical use of data and
tools so that we make sure that
everything that's been consented to has
been is implemented and used this
guidance
why a distributed versus a centralized
version just to kind of drive this point
home
I put this example in that happened
recently in the airline industry where
thousands and thousands of flights were
canceled and delayed because uh here
from the news New York Times it says the
FAA said that it traced the problem to a
damaged database file there was no
evidence cyber Tech but it was a
database file so that's the idea that if
you have a system with one big
centralized component that everything
connects to that if that fails that the
whole network is
um in Jeopardy that's the vulnerability
that we hope to prevent so the nine-data
ecosystem foreign
should not have any centralized
component that would cause a
vulnerability to the entire network
and so we are moving then from data
Discovery so far it was all about
metadata and data Discovery to access
you know as I mentioned you know Ai and
machines to be able to visit the data
and we do swarm learning all these kind
of things which is great vision but we
are not there yet so in the meantime we
have uh interims
stage where here is the catalog again
data from research networks goes to
repositories here and in yellow the
metadata comes along the metadata is
cataloged in the catalog but the data
stay in the repositories and the
metadata will point back to those
repositories but how does the data
access work well the metadata contains
information about the access protocol
and so there are different ways that
after a researcher in the catalog has
found and discovered the data that
they're interested in uh there's
different ways to get to it and that's
specified so you may need to click a
link that will be super easy or you need
to complete the data access request form
or you may have to email the pi of the
center to ask for the data there may be
all kinds of ways that are currently
used for people to use get access to
data but
um that need to be followed because we
cannot in one step change all the ways
people are using data access there's too
many variability and too many honestly
people are very attached to certain ways
of dealing so we can preserve that but
at least as a first step get the
discovery part addressed later we will
move to data access so that's kind of
the stepwise approach
the goal that we should all keep in mind
as we're doing this data infrastructure
building is that we want to accelerate
new discovery this is really clear in
our minds we are working in the night
admission area we are working to fight
in fact his and immune mediated diseases
that's why the data and the tools are
for in our field in our office and we
want to drive these discoveries as
examples are here or for using multiple
data sets and then move towards those
discoveries so that's the goal of the
whole thing
now a couple of comments on data sharing
because I think that's really important
to think about those principles and then
a little bit about the funding
opportunities and fellowships that are
related to some of this work
so data science and data sharing are
interdependent this is a very simple
slide but I think it's really important
to realize that
for offices like ours where we are
working on the science
and on the infrastructure and on the
computational tools and on the data the
sharing part of data are really
really closely connected to that data
science depends on the availability of
real world data
so data sharing is necessary to get the
data to the data science and also draw
The Sciences
but also data sharing is made easier by
methods and Technologies developed in
data science and so but the data sharing
has a lot more of that human kind of
component to it that we sometimes think
about and so I'll show you some of the
example so rapid sharing this is an
example where rapid sharing of data has
made a dramatic effect on the world
really here is uh sharing by
investigators in China of the sarsko V2
genome sequence so in January 5th 2020
the announcement was made to wh
then
five days later
Eddie Holmes published the initial
genome sequence of the coronavirus on
virological.org the data was there very
briefly afterwards a couple of weeks the
data appeared was published here in the
journal and it was deposited in genbank
and the entire sequence here on the
right side was made available for
everybody to use and so that's that step
in within a month of the announcement
and the data sharing and even faster
than that in biological.org led to
massive consequence because that
accelerated the development of
countermeasures and this is just one
example of work that happened at niaid
and in collaboration with researchers is
the um
is the structure of the spike protein
that could then be discovered on which
the modern undefizer vaccine and many
other Therapeutics and countermeasures
were developed so that's just showing
how that data sharing was so important
but data sharing is not easy data
sharing is a major major Challenge and
it has a lot of very very
um
complicated layers to it and I'm not
going to show you this video but I would
highly encourage you to watch it it's
somewhat funny but also somewhat sad
because it really describes what a lot
of us are experiencing in terms of data
sharing so I won't give it away but
please take a look
there are barriers to data sharing and
the berries are not new and well known
and have existed for a long time but we
do want to try to make improvements so
this is one something we published in
2014 already about barriers to data
sharing and public health and there are
really multiple layers to this one is
just technical stuff like you know how
to share the data where's the data
located how do I upload the data it's
too big those kinds of things
but then there are five more layers to
this one is motivational right issues
about scientific credit maybe criticism
maybe there may be errors in the data
there's economical issues around sharing
proprietary data or sensitive political
situations when you want to share
um outbreak data on in a country
this happened in South Africa so when
the Omicron variant emerged the South
African teams shared the data very
rapidly and the announcement that they
had this um this happen and what
happened is that all the airports were
closed around the world to Travelers
from that country and that was clearly
at their loss so that that kind of
disincentivizes data sharing right and
then there is legal and ethical issues
as well so there are these layers to it
that's I think real should keep in mind
that if you work on the technical part
there are other parts to think about
then go into Data sharing a little bit
more at the NIH context NIH has a
20-year history and probably even longer
of data sharing policies to improve data
sharing starting in 23 with the native
sharing policy for large research
genomic data sharing policy clinical
trials and now the NIH data management
and sharing policy many of you may know
that last January this policy came into
effect that now is aiming to maximize
sharing of scientific data in a broad
sense
um this has a long history at NIH of
trying to lead up to this policy
um and the final policy is listed here
and uh to point out there are lots of
related announcements here that give all
kinds of contacts and implementation
details and further guidance on how to
use this policy
and our office at niaid as I said we are
thinking about data sharing and
governance as well so this policy
implementation is also something that we
are thinking a lot about there's a good
website at an age about this and I'm not
going into the policy in detail now but
there is a lot of really good
information on this brand new website at
NIH created
so kind of coming to the end about this
section about challenges
um that we all I think could think about
and need to work on one is representing
metadata that matters in machine
interpolable format that is something
that we said not just the metadata about
the author and the Creator but also the
methods use the provenance of the data
set the quality and the uncertainties in
the data so there are lots of things
that the metadata can definitely still
be improved on
interoperability is an incredible
challenge both at the systems level as
well as the data level and including
semantic interoperability just the fact
that a data set has the variable age in
it one data set has age the other data
set is age a simple thing like age you
can have two entirely different meanings
in two different data sets so we are not
even close to getting the semantics
resolved in interoperability space
that's why Fair findable accessible
intro operability reusable everybody's
recognized that I in the fair principles
is very very difficult to achieve
cost of Legacy data of course historical
observations future sustainability of
the data as a major challenge gaps in
Knowledge and Skills in the map I
already mentioned that there are
computational methods become more and
more complex data curation is becoming
more and more complex and specialized so
how do we bring that into the biomedical
research Community there are ethical
concerns real ethical concerns about
Equity inclusivity reciprocity benefit
sharing privacy you know how much can
de-identification really still happen
um especially with a lot of new
technologies very difficult data sharing
and use limitations
but also the academic culture cultural
things there's an undeniable fact that a
lot of career advancement in Academia is
based on Publications which can lead to
disincentives for data sharing and I
think it would help to just be honest
about that because that is what a lot of
driving factors are and I don't think
anybody needs to be blamed for how this
works but it is the fact of life and so
um we are uh all have to take a role in
trying to
um bring about a culture change where
um work on data and data access and
methods and tools and software is also
recognized as valid academic
contributions and then lastly a little
bit of the the what are we doing
um we've just started I said the office
is relatively new
just to point you to some things that
are starting to come up and I encourage
everybody to really take a close look
and keep following what's happening
at niaid so
um I've kind of put these phases here of
our strategy
um all the way from data to analyzing
and then some funding opportunity
announcements that have been tied to
this now some of these are short-term
announcements that have already closed
or close to closing I'm just showing
this as a illustration and of course in
future years things will keep coming up
so be aware of the activity and how to
follow this along so we have
Awards and notices out to for secondary
data analysis using existing data and
analyzing them for new purposes the 90
ecosystem and there's a notice out for
administrative supplements to prepare
data assets to be included and connected
to this ecosystem
there is a supplement out for training
r25 Based training there is software
announcements out for u01 applications
to develop software for data science in
infectious intermitted diseases we have
a partnership with NSF called smart and
connected Health that brings teams of
computational scientists and data
science biomedical scientists together
to develop Technologies and new methods
for infection immediate disease and also
many other this is a cross-trans NIH
there is sbir small business uh contract
topics on data science for small
businesses to develop tools methods
software Etc and there is this is
recently closed U24 databases and
knowledge bases to support the
development of those
and so I would say
both on the nyad it's data
science.9.nh.gov we are developing more
more information about funding
opportunities that are related to our
strategy and also really keep a close
eye on the NIH office of data science
strategy odss
that is a cross NIH office that has a
lot of activities on data science that
are in all of the institutes and centers
of NIH and there is a lot of overlap and
connectivity between the different
activities in the different centers and
Institutes
um
I want to put in one note about K Awards
and about because this is for junior
faculty and uh as Jack mentioned
um it would not have been because of a
ko1 that I received from the big data to
knowledge program that Jack is part of
and many of us were part of that allowed
me to cross-train from epidemiology and
clinical work to
informatics research and data science
and because of that I could build up
work and really again some expertise in
in biomedical informatics and so I would
highly encourage anybody to look at this
not just at night but also elsewhere the
nyad interest in Ko ones is specifically
for data science
Naya this is the text from the foa here
uses ko1 in the fields of epidemiology
and data science which includes not
limited to computational modeling
bioinformatics Big Data Advanced risk
analysis for infectious and immune
mediated diseases so check that out
there is also a k25 that attracts
investigators quantitative sciences and
Engineering research to then focus on
the nyad mission area more details on
the career awards that nyad are on the
website here below so that's really
recommended lastly there are fellowships
as well inside niaid and also across NIH
related to data science it's a real
opportunity to bring talented data
scientists into NIH which the more data
science Talent we have at NIH the easier
and effective we will be at the
designing you know effective programs in
data science so we need the talent as
well
uh at night we have a fellowship program
called the emerging leaders in data
science Fellowship elf program since
2018 12 fellows have completed currently
five are enrolled we are currently
evaluating this program and we hope to
recruit again next year
so stay tuned for that those are for uh
graduate student
graduates Masters or doctoral level
there is the data national service
program uh data and Technology
advancement so the data Scholars at NIH
is across NIH coordinated by the office
of data science strategy
for experienced data scientists to spend
one or two years at NH it's a tremendous
opportunity to basically either
completely transition or to just
temporarily work at an age on data
science
there is a Civic digital Fellowship for
undergrads there is a triple A S sciency
technology policy fellowship program for
phds MDS or other science and
engineering degrees also for a couple
years at NIH and then at my end I put a
link to our intramural training program
there is intramural training fellowships
for post back all the way through the
postdoc level
that allow in different types of
configurations and models
students or postdocs to come to NIH to
niad at the intramural divisions
where also a lot of data science
research is taking place and those are
sometimes really nice
opportunities to conduct research inside
the NIH labs
so lots of things to look at and I would
say close with open for any questions or
comments and also do follow us along on
the website data
science.9.gov and there's an email
address if you are any questions you can
email the office
and with that back to Jack Wilbert thank
you so much you know I was really glad
that you brought up the office of data
science strategy um because one of the
things I was wondering about is how the
individual NIH institutes are all
interoperable with each other at least
in so far as coming up with overall
strategy and I was curious if you might
say a few more words about uh what sort
of more Global NIH Vision there might be
yeah that's even a good point
um you know NIH is like a Federation of
uh individual institutes and centers as
I mentioned there are 27 of them many of
them have their own funding lines and so
it's really a collaborative effort
between the different institutes many of
the institutes are setting up offices of
data science
um just like ours to keep those and make
those connections so there are lots of
working groups and thoughts mostly
coordinated by office of data science
strategy but also by others to align the
strategies and I have to say
uh it's really really exciting to see
all the um interest and the work that's
taking place but on the other hand of
course
um there are lots of individual
approaches that could lead to some silos
and some disconnects and so the need to
move fast in certain places could lead
to some um
some solutions and systems and networks
and ecosystems that go in a certain
direction that may not be compatible
with others but I would say the vision
is for this what I just showed ecosystem
across NIH to connect the data and to
make things interoperable but the
implementation is a major Challenge and
as some implementations are moving
forward
others that come later may not fully
connect to that but there is there is a
lot of effort to do make those
connections but there is a real tension
between institutes and centers like nyad
to move forward in their space while at
the same time staying in sync with 27
other institutes and centers and so it's
just a uh a logistical and operational
and cultural challenge but in the end
the community is converging around
things and NIH is converging around
things as well so
um you know what it's so positive about
it it's super interesting because I'm a
neuroscientist by trade and one of the
things that the NIH has always kind of
had it perhaps it wasn't always front
and center but has had an interest in
data and computation computational
modeling and even though it wasn't
necessarily kind of like out there in at
least in neurosciences like
experimentalists and theoreticians uh
like Fitzhugh and coal and various
people who are fundamental and
understanding say like neuronal
membranes did a lot of their
computational and mathematical work at
the NIH on the main campus and so it has
a long history of it and so it's always
I think exciting to see the the NIH kind
of recognizing that it itself has a
history and that um you know data is the
new oil and that certainly is the case
in biomedicine I hope you agree
absolutely yeah it is exciting to see
and I wouldn't you know the what struck
me as being new to NIH was the um the
very large intramural community of the
scientists working inside the Institute
and I have to and then there's of course
the extramural part that is supporting
the extramural community and
um we are privileged in our office that
we can look at both
um places but um it's also nice to see
as you said that there are lots of
advances uh the intramural Labs I think
are very competitive places to work and
they are moving into data science and
now for example our vaccine Research
Center
um has already been using even for the
moderna vaccine
um Ai and
um an alpha fold and protein folding
methods to do rational intelligent
vaccine design and look at uh epitope
targets for vaccines and so these
methods are being used more and more
images are the other one image
recognition and there's a tremendous
amount of image data being generated
both clinical imagery but also electron
microscope inventory where we want to
use Ai and some of the lamps are
starting to use that so I do think
there's actually quite a promising
career path submerging inside NIH for
data scientists as well it's nice to see
you kind of go through some of the the
barriers that people have in front of
them when considering to share their
data and you mentioned things like you
know just
um people just generally concerned at a
cultural level I mean we're all humans
after all and that people are concerned
about their own well-being their
promotion and tenure about having their
work scooped by somebody else before
they had a chance to kind of go and
extract the Nobel Prize that I'm sure
they all think is lurking in their data
um but also I've had an experience uh in
data sharing where people were not
interested in Sharing data because they
said oh I couldn't possibly explain it
to you
and I couldn't explain what we did to
you
and when we sort of pointed out that
that might not really be considered
science they they got a little upset
about that but the cultural things are
so important and I'm wondering if
there's any way that you know the NIH
being the you know thousand pound
gorilla in the room has any sort of
Leverage to to help people understand
that no this is this is really important
and we need to do this these cultural
things maybe the NIH can help with those
is there anything that those questions
come up absolutely I mean this is a one
of the most common kind of
um concerns is not the malicious concern
that I don't want you to use my data but
it's also a kind of a prudent scientists
that are under so many complexities but
then as you mentioned
um the reproducibility in science is a
is a key tenet and foundation of the
entire scientific process so being able
to reproduce you need to understand what
others did and that's why you know the
whole peer review and everything is
based on so but that's that's not often
kind of how people feel so what NIH can
do I mean the policy was published right
and the policy Uh current policies is is
asking for maximum data sharing and that
indicates the policy does not require
data sharing that's one thing I wanted
to make clear the policy still leaves
openings for legitimate reasons like
privacy or intellectual property or
other types of things to not share data
but the overall push is to maximize data
sharing and that
um
somebody not being able to explain their
methodology to somebody else is not
listed among a legitimate reason so of
course the implementation and the
enforcement of the policy are major
questions but the um the push is there
and the official institutional policy of
that this is what we want to see is
there and that will have quite an effect
on the community but then at the same
time
um it also will require training and
education and bringing the Next
Generation like what you're doing with
your program bringing the Next
Generation online and as the as the
scientific Community kind of starts to
transition
um the NIH will also be part of that but
there is a tension between
taking the lead and being like too much
of an of an enforcer versus
um kind of following where the
communities also going so I think that's
part of the process but definitely there
was a major role and I think NH is very
interested in in engaging with the
community on this
Wilbert thank you so very much for
sharing the vision from the NIH today
um we really appreciate you sharing that
with us
um and it sounds like you're hiring so
you know if there's anybody out there
who's looking for a job absolutely
it's an exciting time for data science
and biomedicine exciting time at the NIH
and so hopefully people will take
advantage of that and uh in the meantime
uh Wilbert thank you again have a
wonderful weekend everybody who joined
us have a wonderful weekend and we will
see you next week
thank you